Our episodes deal with serious and often distressing incidents. If you feel at any time you need support, please contact your local crisis centre. For suggested phone numbers for confidential support, please see the show notes for this episode on your app or on our website. Southern Cross Station is the second busiest railway station in Melbourne, with more than nine million passenger movements recorded between 2007 and 2008. As well as being served by the city's suburban train services, Southern Cross is the terminus for the State of Victoria's Regional Rail Network.
我们的节目涉及严重且往往令人痛心的事件。如果您在任何时候觉得需要支持，请联系您当地的危机中心。有关保密支持的建议电话号码，请查看您使用的应用程序或我们网站上的本集节目简介。南十字车站是墨尔本第二繁忙的火车站，2007年至2008年间记录的旅客吞吐量超过九百万人次。除了该市的市郊列车服务外，南十字车站还是维多利亚州区域铁路网的终点站。
A shopping complex adjoins the station, and underneath is a coach terminal providing buses to interstate and regional destinations, as well as the Skybus shuttle service that travels to Melbourne's Tullamareen Airport. For security purposes, a number of closed-circuit television cameras are placed at strategic locations throughout. On Saturday, September 15, 2007, just after 10am, an elderly Chinese couple were walking through Southern Cross Station when they noticed a female toddler standing alone near the escalator.
车站旁连接着一个购物综合体，地下是一个长途汽车客运站，提供前往州际和区域目的地的巴士，以及开往墨尔本图拉马林机场的天空巴士穿梭服务。出于安全考虑，多处战略位置都安装了闭路电视摄像头。2007年9月15日星期六上午10点刚过，一对年迈的中国夫妇正走过南十字车站，这时他们注意到一个女幼儿独自站在自动扶梯旁。
She was of Asian appearance and looked to be around three years old. She had short dark hair cut in a bob and wore a red denim hooded jacket, an aqua-coloured vest with a red and pink diamond pattern, and bright pink corduroy pants. Thinking the toddler might have been lost, the couple approached and attempted to speak to her. When she didn't respond, they beckoned a Victoria Rail employee named Marino Michuglu over to see if he could help. While trying to speak with the child, Marino patted her on the head and immediately noticed
她有着亚洲人的外貌，看起来大约三岁。她留着短短的波波头短红色深色发，穿着一件红色牛仔连帽夹克、一件带有红粉相间菱形图案的水蓝色背心，以及一条亮粉色灯芯绒裤子。这对夫妇以为这个幼儿可能走失了，便走上前去试图跟她说话。见她没有反应，他们招手叫来了一名名叫马里诺·米舒格卢的维多利亚铁路员工，看看他能否帮忙。在试图与孩子交谈时，马里诺轻轻拍了拍她的头，并立即注意到
that her hair was very greasy as though it hadn't been washed in some time. There was no sign of any frantic parents looking for their lost child, so Marino decided to summon police to the scene. Responding officers also attempted to communicate with the child, but she was either unwilling or unable to tell them her name. Knowing that the vest she was wearing was made by a popular children's clothing brand called Pumpkin Patch, they decided to nickname her Pumpkin until a proper identification could be made.
她的头发非常油腻，就像很久没洗过一样。现场没有看到任何惊慌失措的父母在寻找他们走失的孩子，于是马里诺决定叫警察到现场。出警的警员也试图与孩子沟通，但她要么不愿、要么无法告诉他们自己的名字。由于知道她身上穿的背心是由一个名为“南瓜田”的知名童装品牌制造的，他们决定给她起个昵称叫“南瓜”，直到确认真实身份为止。
The girl's clothing provided no real clue to her identity, as although the Pumpkin Patch brand was based in New Zealand, it was sold widely throughout Australia. On her unwashed hair, Pumpkin appeared to be a healthy, well cared for child who was appropriately dressed in clean clothing. The police took her into their care, hoping she was merely lost and her parents would soon come forward to claim her. When no one did, they scoured CCTV footage from Southern Cross Station and quickly realized that Pumpkin had been deliberately abandoned.
女孩的衣服并没有为她的身份提供真正的线索，因为尽管“南瓜田”品牌总部设在新西兰，但它在澳大利亚各地广泛销售。除了她那没洗过的头发外，“南瓜”看起来是一个健康、照顾得很好的孩子，穿着干净得体的衣服。警方将她接走照顾，希望她只是迷路了，她的父母很快就会来认领她。当没有人来时，他们搜查了南十字车站的闭路电视监控录像，很快意识到“南瓜”是被蓄意遗弃的。
At 10am on Saturday, September 15, 2007, the Southern Cross security cameras had captured Pumpkin as she walked through the station's street level lobby, hand in hand with a middle-aged, dark-haired man of Asian appearance. The man was dressed in black trousers and a grey suit jacket, and was pulling a small suitcase on wheels in his left hand. When the pair reached the base of an escalator that led to the upper floor, the man seemingly instructed Pumpkin to remain where she was, before stepping onto the escalator alone. Upon reaching the first floor, he glanced back briefly, then continued striding purposefully
2007年9月15日星期六上午10点，南十字车站的安全摄像头拍下了“南瓜”穿过车站街层大厅的画面，她手拉着一个中年、黑发、亚洲面孔的男子。这名男子穿着黑色裤子和灰色西装外套，左手拉着一个小轮式行李箱。当两人走到通往二楼的自动扶梯底部时，这名男子似乎指示“南瓜”留在原地，然后独自踏上了自动扶梯。到达二楼后，他简短地回头看了一眼，然后继续坚定地大步向前。
ahead. The young child remained standing all by herself at the base of the escalator, barely moving, as though she was trying her best to stay still. After viewing the footage, multilingual staff from Victoria Police attempted to converse with Pumpkin, and a number of different interpreters were summoned, but none succeeded in communicating with her. The following day of Sunday, September 16, the Department of Human Services arranged for Pumpkin to be placed with an emergency foster family.
小女孩独自一人站在自动扶梯底部，几乎一动不动，好像在竭尽全力保持静止。观看监控录像后，维多利亚州警察局的多语种工作人员试图与“南瓜”交谈，并请来了几位不同的口译员，但都没有成功与她沟通。第二天，即9月16日星期日，人类服务部安排将“南瓜”寄养在一个紧急寄养家庭。
That same day, the police shared the CCTV footage as part of a public appeal for the girl's parents, extended family members, or anyone who recognized her to come forward. They reported that although Pumpkin had been through a considerable ordeal and wasn't speaking to anybody, she had appeared happy and perky overnight. Media outlets soon started sharing Pumpkin's story in an effort to discover who she was and why she had been separated from her family. Members of the public immediately began contacting Victoria Police to say that they recognized the pair, with a number of calls coming from the neighboring country of New Zealand.
当天，警方分享了闭路电视监控录像，作为公众呼吁的一部分，寻找女孩的父母、其他家庭成员或任何认得她的人站出来。他们报告说，“南瓜”虽然经历了一番折磨，不跟任何人说话，但过了一夜后显得开心而有精神。各大媒体很快开始传播“南瓜”的故事，试图查明她是谁以及她为什么与家人分离。公众成员立即开始联系维多利亚州警方，称他们认出了这两人，其中有几个电话来自邻国新西兰。
The callers believed the man captured on camera was Nguyen Xue, a 53-year-old martial arts instructor and prominent member of the Chinese community from Auckland, New Zealand. The girl he had abandoned was believed to be his three-year-old daughter, Chen Xun Xue. One individual reported seeing the father and daughter while on board a flight from Auckland to Melbourne several days earlier, on Thursday, September 13. They obtained the flight's passenger manifest and examined the list of individuals who had been on board. Based on this information, they confirmed that Pumpkin was in fact Chen Xun Xue and
打电话的人认为监控器里拍到的男子是阮雪（音译，Nguyen Xue），他是一名53岁的武术教练，也是新西兰奥克兰华人社区的知名成员。他遗弃的女孩被认为是他的三岁女儿陈勋雪（音译，Chen Xun Xue）。一位目击者报告说，几天前的9月13日星期四，在从奥克兰飞往墨尔本的航班上看到了这对父女。他们获取了该航班的乘客名单，并检查了机上人员名单。根据这些信息，他们确认“南瓜”实际上就是陈勋雪，而
the man was her father, Nguyen Xue. Further inquiries revealed that upon landing in Melbourne, Xue had told custom agents that he and his daughter were visiting the city for a holiday. However, later that evening when they checked in at a hotel, Xue told the hotel's porter that he was permanently relocating to Melbourne. He had even inquired about the best area to live and where to purchase a car. The following morning of Friday, September 14, Xue had visited a travel agency in Melbourne's Central Business District and attempted to book a flight to the US city of Los Angeles
那名男子是她的父亲阮雪。进一步调查显示，阮雪在墨尔本降落后，曾告诉海关人员，他和女儿是来该市度假的。然而，当天傍晚晚些时候，当他们在酒店登记入住时，阮雪告诉酒店门童，他将永久搬迁到墨尔本。他甚至打听了哪个区域最适合居住以及在哪里买车。第二天，即9月14日星期五，阮雪参观了墨尔本中央商务区的一家旅行社，并试图预订当天傍晚飞往美国洛杉矶的航班。
that evening. When the travel agent informed him there weren't any direct flights available, Xue queried about connecting flights from other locations before settling on a direct flight from Melbourne to Los Angeles scheduled for the following day. Approximately 24 hours later, he abandoned Chen Xun at Southern Cross Station and made his way to Melbourne Airport. There, after he successfully passed through a security checkpoint, CCTV cameras caught him smiling widely and flashing two thumbs up.
当旅行社告知他没有直飞航班时，阮雪询问了来自其他地点的转机航班，最后决定预订第二天从墨尔本直飞洛杉矶的航班。大约24小时后，他在南十字车站遗弃了陈勋，并前往墨尔本机场。在那里，在成功通过安检后，闭路电视摄像头拍到他开怀大笑并竖起了两个大拇指。
By the end of Sunday, September 16, police had solved the mystery of Chen Xun's identity, but two new questions had sprung up in its place. They now had to figure out why Nguyen Xue had left his daughter alone at a busy railway station and the whereabouts of his wife and Chen Xun's mother, 28-year-old Anen Liao. Based on the evidence uncovered so far, there was no indication she had travelled to Melbourne with her family. Anen Liao was born on February 20, 1979 in Chauncha, the capital city of China's Hunan province.
到9月16日星期日结束时，警方解开了陈勋身份之谜，但随之涌现出了两个新问题。他们现在必须弄清楚为什么阮雪要把女儿独自留在繁忙的火车站，以及他的妻子兼陈勋的母亲、28岁的安恩廖（音译，Anen Liao）的下落。根据迄今为止发现的证据，没有任何迹象表明她曾与家人一起去过墨尔本。安恩廖于1979年2月20日出生在中国湖南省省会长沙。
She was the only child to prosperous parents and grew up to have a range of interests, including reading, listening to music, singing karaoke, and watching films. Her all-time favourite movie was Chinese Odyssey, a 1995 two-part feature based on a classic 16th century novel set during the Ming dynasty. As well as having an interest in pop culture, Anen was an active person who played badminton and enjoyed going out driving. Having lived her entire life in a bustling, popular city, Anen often dreamed of visiting an idyllic island or forest and also hoped to move overseas one day.
她是富裕家庭的独生女，长大后有着广泛的兴趣，包括阅读、听音乐、唱卡拉OK和看电影。她有史以来最喜欢的电影是1995年的两部分别取材于明代经典16世纪小说的电影《大话西游》。除了对流行文化感兴趣外，安恩是一个活跃的人，她打羽毛球，喜欢开车外出。安恩一生都在一个繁华、受欢迎的城市生活，她经常梦想去一个田园诗般的岛屿或森林，也希望有一天能移居海外。
In April 2002, at the age of 23, she achieved both goals by moving to New Zealand, a small island country renowned for its striking natural beauty. Anen had applied for a student visa to study English and she set herself up in the city of Auckland on the country's North Island. At the time, Auckland was home to a rapidly growing Chinese community, but its insularity and disconnection from New Zealand's broader population meant that many new arrivals battled with feelings of isolation. People like Anen, who had difficulty speaking English, struggled even more.
2002年4月，23岁的她通过移居新西兰实现了这两个目标，这是一个以迷人自然风光而闻名的小岛国。安恩申请了学生签证去学习英语，并在该国北岛的奥克兰市安顿下来。当时，奥克兰是迅速增长的华人社区的家园，但其孤立性以及与新西兰更广泛人口的脱节，意味着许多新来者都在与孤立感作斗争。像安恩这样英语说得不好的人，挣扎得更加厉害。
Although she was happy to be in New Zealand, Anen often felt lonely in her new home. She initially moved in with another woman, but in early 2003, she began renting a room at the home of Nain Shwey, who was aged in his late 40s at the time. Shwey was born in 1954 in the city of Te Ling in northeast China. During early adulthood, he worked as a middle school physical education teacher and lived for a time in Los Angeles. He eventually returned to China where he married his first wife and in 1981, the two had a daughter they named Grace.
尽管很高兴能来到新西兰，但安恩在新家经常感到孤独。她最初与另一个女人合住，但在2003年初，她开始在南·施韦（音译，Nain Shwey）的家中租一个房间，当时他已经快五十岁了。施韦于1954年出生在中国东北的铁岭市。在青年时期，他曾担任中学体育教师，并在洛杉矶生活过一段时间。他最终回到中国，在那里与他的第一任妻子结婚，并在1981年生下了一个女儿，他们给女儿起名叫格蕾丝（Grace）。
10 years later, Shwey immigrated to New Zealand alone, leaving his family behind. Shwey had a passion for martial arts and was convinced that it was his destiny to share his unique blend of kung fu and tai chi with others around the world. After moving to Auckland, Shwey began holding martial arts classes in a Chinese restaurant, where he predominantly taught Wu style tai chi. His program was a success and he soon upgraded to a larger venue in Auckland's central business district, before eventually relocating his school to a sprawling parkland in the inner city suburb of Epsom.
10年以后，施韦独自一人移民新西兰，将家人抛在脑后。施韦对武术有着极大的热情，并坚信将自己独特的功夫与太极融合分享给世界各地的人是他的宿命。搬到奥克兰后，施韦开始在一个中餐馆举办武术班，他主要在那里教授吴式太极拳。他的计划取得了成功，他很快升级到奥克兰中央商务区的一个更大场地，最后将他的学校搬到了内城埃普索姆（Epsom）郊区的一个广阔公园。
He told his students he had learned his martial arts skills from a man with a long white beard whom he had encountered when playing in the mountains as a child. The fairytale-like story was eventually published in local Chinese-language newspapers, drawing more students and increasing Shwey's business. Within a few years of arriving in New Zealand, Shwey obtained citizenship and became something of a local celebrity in Auckland's Chinese community. In 1998, he further enhanced his own mythos by self-publishing an autobiography titled The Pearl of Wu Style Tai Chi.
他告诉学生，他的武术技能是一位留着长白胡子的老人传授给他的，那是他在童年时在山上游玩时偶然遇到的。这个童话般的故事最终发表在当地的中文报纸上，吸引了更多的学生，并增加了施韦的生意。来到新西兰几年后，施韦获得了公民身份，并在奥克兰的华人社区成了某种当地名人。1998年，他通过自费出版一本名为《吴式太极拳之珍珠》的自传，进一步提升了自己的神话色彩。
In the book, Shwey claimed to have been conceived by magic. Before he was born, his aging, childless mother allegedly went to a temple to pray for a son. While there, she had a vision in which an elderly man told her she would have a baby boy who would grow up to be a great and successful man. Shortly afterwards, she became pregnant. In early 2003, Shwey took Annen into his home as a border on the condition that she cleaned the house in exchange for her room. Shortly into this arrangement, Annen confided that her student visa was due to expire.
在这本书中，施韦声称自己是通过魔法受孕的。在他出生之前，他年迈且没有孩子的母亲据称去了一座寺庙祈求生个儿子。在那里，她有了一个异象，一位老头告诉她，她会生下一个男孩，长大后将成为一个伟大而成功的人。不久之后，她怀孕了。2003年初，施韦将安恩作为寄宿生接到家中，条件是她打扫房子以换取房间。在这种安排刚开始不久，安恩吐露说她的学生签证即将到期。
She wanted to stay in New Zealand but couldn't afford the tuition fees required to continue studying and therefore wouldn't be able to renew her visa. Shwey was aware that marrying a New Zealand citizen would be an alternative way for Annen to remain in the country and suddenly proposed to her in a roundabout fashion by asking, What about me? Even though there was a 25-year age difference between the two, Annen felt she didn't have any other options if she wanted to stay in New Zealand. She agreed to marry Shwey, believing that his many accomplishments and high standing
她想留在新西兰，但承担不起继续学习所需的学费，因此无法续签签证。施韦知道与新西兰公民结婚是安恩留在该国的另一种方式，于是他拐弯抹角地向她求婚，问道：“我怎么样？”尽管两人之间有25岁的年龄差距，但安恩觉得如果她想留在新西兰，自己别无选择。她同意嫁给施韦，认为他的许多成就和在社区中的崇高地位是她丈夫应有的品质。两人开始了一段恋爱关系，并于2003年7月28日在奥克兰婚姻登记处结婚。
in the community were worthy qualities in her husband. The pair began a romantic relationship and on July 28, 2003, they were married at an Auckland registry office. On the day of their wedding, Annen was already four months pregnant with their first child. In September 2003, Annen applied for New Zealand residency. Three months later, on December 22, she gave birth to Chen Shun. Shwey was reportedly disappointed that the baby wasn't a boy but Annen adored her and the mother and daughter became inseparable.
在他们结婚那天，安恩已经怀有他们第一个孩子四个月了。2003年9月，安恩申请了新西兰居留权。三个月后的12月22日，她生下了陈顺。据报道，施韦对生下的不是个男孩感到失望，但安恩对她疼爱有加，母女俩形影不离。
To those who knew Annen, it made no sense that she would stay in New Zealand while her husband took their daughter to a foreign country. On Monday, September 17, 2007, the day after Victoria police confirmed Chen Shun's identity, she finally spoke her first words to authorities by asking for her mother. Victoria police had been in touch with their counterparts in Auckland who said about trying to contact Annen Leal. Her mobile phone was switched off so they headed to the family's residence, a white weatherboard house on Keystone Avenue in the southwestern suburb of Mount Roscoe.
对于认识安恩的人来说，她留在新西兰而丈夫带着女儿去外国是毫无道理的。2007年9月17日星期一，即维多利亚州警方确认陈顺身份的第二天，她终于通过询问她的母亲向当局说出了她的第一句话。维多利亚州警方与奥克兰的同行取得了联系，后者表示正在努力联系安恩·莱尔（Anen Leal）。她的手机关机了，于是他们前往该家庭的住所，那是位于西南部埃普索姆郊区基斯顿大道（Keystone Avenue）的一栋白色木板房。
The police found no sign of Annen at the property, nor was her vehicle there, but Shwey's Honda Rafaga sedan was parked out the front. Police also checked Annen's bank accounts and discovered there had been no activity since Monday, September 10, 2007. On Tuesday, September 18, investigators publicly urged Shwey to contact law enforcement. They confirmed they were working to track him down with the International Criminal Police Organization, better known as Interpol, and openly labelled his fleeing with Chen Shun as a kidnapping.
警方在房产处没有发现安恩的踪迹，她的车也不在那里，但施韦的本田拉法加（Rafaga）轿车停在门前。警方还检查了安恩的银行账户，发现自2007年9月10日星期一以来没有任何交易活动。9月18日星期二，调查人员公开敦促施韦联系执法部门。他们确认正在与国际刑警组织（更广为人知的名称是国际刑警组织，Interpol）合作追踪他的下落，并公开将他带着陈顺潜逃的行为定性为绑架。
That same day, police found Annen's car parked at Auckland's International Airport, though they were certain she hadn't left the country. CCTV cameras at the airport had captured Shwey and Chen Shun checking in and proceeding through customs, but there was no evidence to indicate that Annen had ever been there. The police returned to the family's Mount Roscoe home and cordoned it off in anticipation of a forensic examination. At nine o'clock that night, a search warrant was issued for the property and for Shwey's vehicle.
当天，警方在奥克兰国际机场发现了安恩停放的汽车，尽管他们确信她没有离开这个国家。机场的闭路电视摄像头拍下了施韦和陈顺办理登机手续并通过海关的画面，但没有证据表明安恩曾去过那里。警方返回了安恩位于奥克兰的家中，并拉起警戒线，准备进行法医勘查。当晚九点，法院对该房产以及施韦的汽车发出了搜查令。
Investigators examined the residents more closely, but found nothing of note. Shwey's car was towed to a secure location and given a preliminary examination, but nothing of interest was found. A more thorough search was scheduled for the following day. On Wednesday, September 19, additional police officers in Auckland were briefed on the case and at 1pm, an extensive forensic search of Shwey's Honda Rafaga commenced. Once investigators gained access to the car, they opened its boot and immediately made a shocking discovery.
调查人员对居民进行了更仔细的检查，但没有发现任何值得注意的东西。施韦的车被拖到一个安全地点并进行了初步检查，但没有发现任何引起兴趣的线索。更彻底的搜查计划在第二天进行。9月19日星期三，奥克兰的更多警员听取了案件简报，下午1点，对施韦本田拉法加汽车的大规模法医搜查开始了。一旦调查人员进入车内，他们便打开了后备箱，并立即做出了一个令人震惊的发现。
Inside, was the body of a young woman of Chinese ethnicity, covered with a dressing gown. Beneath the gown, the woman was naked except for a pair of gloves. A yellow necktie was wrapped around her throat and red women's underwear and a jacket were found lying next to her body. And one of the jacket's pockets were two men's rings, one of which was a wedding band. The body was positively identified as Annen Leal and an autopsy was carried out the following morning. It was determined that Annen had been strangled to death with the yellow tie, most likely
里面是一具年轻中国女性的尸体，盖着一件晨衣。在这件晨衣下面，除了戴着一对手套外，这具女尸赤身裸体。她的脖子上缠着一条黄色的领带，尸体旁边放着一条红色的女式内衣和一件夹克。夹克的一个口袋里有两枚男士戒指，其中一枚是结婚戒指。尸体经确认为安恩·莱尔（Anen Leal），次日上午进行了尸检。经确定，安恩是被那条黄色领带勒死的，最有可能的是
as the killer stood behind her. She had been wearing a pendant around her neck, which had compounded the strangulation. At approximately 3 o'clock that afternoon, the police publicly confirmed that Annen's body had been found. They withheld the cause of her death, but noted it had occurred following a violent incident and that Annen's husband, Nguyen Shwey, was the prime suspect. As the police had taken two days to discover Annen's body, which had been inside her husband's car parked outside their home, some criticized the Auckland police for what they perceived
凶手站在她身后时动的手。她的脖子上一直戴着一条吊坠，这加剧了勒窒息。当天下午大约3点，警方公开确认安恩的尸体已被找到。他们隐瞒了她的死因，但指出这是在一场暴力事件发生后发生的，并且安恩的丈夫阮施韦是头号嫌疑人。由于警方花了两天才发现安恩的尸体——该尸体就在她丈夫停在他们家门外的车里，一些人批评奥克兰警方反应迟缓
as an unnecessarily slow response. A former high-ranking officer told the media the delay was, quote, absolutely appalling and noted it was possible that Annen may have still been alive when she was first placed in the car's boot. While New Zealand's police commissioner Howard Broad admitted that the officers didn't initially believe the car to be of any importance, the Auckland police defended their actions. Detective Senior Sergeant Simon Scott, who was heading the case, clarified that the delay was due to having to wait for the proper search warrant.
是不必要的拖延。前高级警官告诉媒体，这种拖延“绝对令人震惊”，并指出安恩最初被放进汽车后备箱时可能还活着。虽然新西兰警察局长霍华德·布罗德（Howard Broad）承认警员最初并不认为这辆车有什么重要性，但奥克兰警方为他们的行动辩护。负责此案的高级侦探督察西蒙·斯科特（Simon Scott）澄清说，拖延是因为不得不等待适当的搜查令。
He explained, quote, We haven't had the keys for that vehicle, it's just not a matter of breaking the windows and getting in. These things don't take minutes, they could take days or weeks. Many of the family's acquaintances told investigators that Annen and Shwey had appeared content and well-adjusted. They described Annen as a kind but quiet person who embraced motherhood and helped her husband by driving him to and from work each day.
他解释说：“我们没有这辆车的钥匙，这绝不是砸碎窗户进去那么简单。这些事情不会花几分钟，可能需要几天或几周。”许多熟人告诉调查人员，安恩和施韦看起来很满足、很适应。他们将安恩描述为一个善良但安静的人，她拥抱母亲的角色，每天开车接送丈夫上下班来协助他。
However, others had their doubts about the couple's relationship. A friend of Shwey's told investigators he suspected the marriage wasn't based on love but was rather transactional in nature. Shwey had been attracted to Annen's youth and beauty while she had seen him as a means to stay in New Zealand. Shwey's friend believed that the significant age difference between the couple ensured marital problems were inevitable. A male neighbor told a journalist for the New Zealand Herald newspaper that Annen was
然而，其他人对这对夫妇的关系存有疑虑。施韦的一位朋友告诉调查人员，他怀疑这段婚姻不是基于爱，而是带有交易性质。施韦被安恩的年轻和美貌所吸引，而安恩则视他为留在新西兰的途径。施韦的朋友认为，这对夫妇之间显着的年龄差距确保了婚姻问题的不可避免。一名男邻居告诉《新西兰先驱报》的一名记者，安恩
friendly and would often say hello. In contrast, Shwey didn't speak to his neighbors and appeared, quote, a bit kooky, often collecting the mail dressed only in his underwear. It was also revealed that during a trip to China to visit her family with Chen Shun, Annen had an intrauterine contraceptive device inserted to prevent any future pregnancies. Once she obtained New Zealand residency in December 2005, she refused to continue sharing a bed with Shwey. It also came to light that in March 2006, a film student and martial arts enthusiast
很友好，经常打招呼。相比之下，施韦不跟邻居说话，显得“有点古怪”，经常只穿着内裤去收信。另据披露，安恩在与陈顺一起回中国探亲期间，曾植入宫内节育器以防止以后怀孕。2005年12月获得新西兰居留权后，她拒绝继续与施韦同床共枕。还有消息曝光，2006年3月，一名电影学生兼武术爱好者
named Shia Hong had made a nine-minute documentary about Shwey, titled Kung Fu Father. It was supervised by a filmmaker named Tony Wright, and portions of the documentary were filmed in Shwey and Annen's home. Tony told journalists that during filming, he had observed that the walls of the home were decorated with large posters of Shwey demonstrating martial arts poses, rather than with family photographs. A translator had been present on set, who communicated to Tony that Shwey didn't want him to speak to his wife.
名叫谢亚宏（音译，Shia Hong）的人拍摄了一部关于施韦的九分钟纪录片，名为《功夫父亲》。该片由一位名叫托尼·赖特（Tony Wright）的电影制片人监督，纪录片的一部分是在施韦和安恩的家中拍摄的。托尼告诉记者，在拍摄过程中，他观察到家里的墙壁上装饰着施韦展示武术姿势的大幅海报，而不是家庭照片。现场有一名翻译，他向托尼传达了施韦不想让他和妻子说话的意思。
Overall, Tony told journalists that he felt the couple's relationship was one in which, quote, he talked and she listened. Throughout filming, Shwey boasted about his career and claimed to be revered by 40,000 martial arts enthusiasts who were predominantly based in the United States. At one point, he broke down when discussing his daughter from his first marriage, Grace. In the year 2000, when Grace was 19, Shwey had sponsored her to join him in New Zealand. But in 2002, she had run away because he was a neglectful father. Addressing Grace directly, Shwey stated to the camera,
总体而言，托尼告诉记者，他觉得这对夫妇的关系是“他说话，她听着”的那种。在整个拍摄过程中，施韦吹嘘自己的职业生涯，并声称自己受到主要位于美国的4万名武术爱好者的崇拜。在某个时刻，他在谈到他第一段婚姻中的女儿格蕾丝时崩溃了。2000年，当格蕾丝19岁时，施韦曾资助她加入他在新西兰的生活。但在2002年，她离家出走了，因为他是一个疏忽大意的父亲。施韦直接对着镜头对格蕾丝说，
I lost you. I feel such guilt. I put my career first. I was selfish. Daughter, please come back. Give me a chance to remedy those things that Papa did wrong. Saying that he wanted to be a better father to Chen Chun, he stated, My role now is to give this baby more father's love.
我失去了你。我感到非常内疚。我把事业放在第一位。我很自私。女儿，请回来吧。给我一个机会来弥补爸爸做错了的事情。他说他想成为陈顺更好的父亲，并表示：“我现在的角色是给这个孩子更多的父爱。”
Filmmaker Tony Wright told the press that he believed Shwey's tears were false and that the scene had been a hollow performance. Despite Shwey's standing as one of New Zealand's premier martial arts experts, his reputation had been unraveling for some time. In the early 2000s, a group from Auckland's Chinese community had visited a martial arts association in Beijing where Shwey claimed to have trained to become a Tai Chi master. However, the association revealed this was a lie. Shwey had also created discord in Los Angeles where he had lived briefly before immigrating
电影制片人托尼·赖特告诉媒体，他认为施韦的眼泪是假的，这一幕不过是一场空洞的表演。尽管施韦作为新西兰顶尖的武术专家之一享有盛誉，但他的名声一段时间以来一直在瓦解。2000年代初，奥克兰华人社区的一个团体访问了北京的一个武术协会，施韦曾声称他就是在那里训练成为太极大师的。然而，该协会透露这是一个谎言。施韦还在洛杉矶制造了不和，他在移民新西兰之前曾在那里短暂生活过。
to New Zealand. According to the owner of the Tai Chi Academy of Los Angeles, Shwey had been ostracised by the city's Chinese community after he launched scathing attacks on other Tai Chi teachers from around the world. It was also revealed that he had lied about his qualifications. It was around the same time that Shwey's professional reputation was being questioned that his relationship with Annen became increasingly controlling. People outside their marriage noticed signs of domestic violence with one of Shwey's
根据洛杉矶太极学院负责人的说法，施韦在对世界各地的其他太极老师发起尖锐攻击后，被该市的华人社区排挤。另据透露，他在自己的资质上撒了谎。正是在施韦的职业声誉受到性质质疑的同一时期，他对安恩的控制欲也日益加剧。婚姻之外的人注意到了家庭暴力的迹象，施韦的一名
students observing that he often ordered Annen out of the room when he had guests. On two occasions, the student also noticed that Annen's face was bruised and grazed. A longtime friend of Annen's family had witnessed Shwey exhibit explosive rage towards Annen and believed that she bore, quote, the brunt of much of his disappointment in life. On September 20, 2006, one year before Chen Shun was abandoned at Southern Cross Station, Shwey had committed a particularly violent attack against Annen. The couple were arguing about money when Shwey suddenly threw a telephone at Annen who was holding Chen Shun at the time.
学生观察到，当家里有客人时，他经常命令安恩离开房间。有两次，这名学生还注意到安恩的脸上青一块紫一块，还有擦伤。安恩家庭的一位老朋友曾目睹施韦对安恩表现出爆发性的愤怒，并认为她承受了“他生活中大部分失望的重担”。2006年9月20日，即陈顺在南十字车站被遗弃的一年前，施韦对安恩实施了一次特别暴力的袭击。这对夫妇当时正在为钱争吵，施韦突然把一部电话扔向当时正抱着陈顺的安恩。
Annen attempted to shield her daughter from the phone, but it wound up striking the toddler in the head, leaving a small cut and swelling. Shwey then ran towards Annen, who was still holding Chen Shun, and punched her several times in the head. He then held a 30-centimeter long knife to her stomach and stated, quote, I treat you good and you don't treat me very well. I love you, but you don't love me. I am going to kill you.
安恩试图用身体保护女儿免受电话砸中，但电话最终击中了幼儿的头部，留下了一个小伤口并肿了起来。施韦随即冲向仍然抱着陈顺的安恩，朝她的头部打了好几拳。然后，他把一把30厘米长的刀架在她的肚皮上，并说道：“我对你好，你却对我不怎么好。我爱你，你却不爱我。我要杀了你。”
Annen begged for her life and threw money at Shwey in an attempt to placate him before fleeing the house with Chen Shun. She reported the assault to the police, and a government agency called Child Youth and Family became involved. On September 29, 2006, a temporary protection order was issued against Shwey, and a permanent protection order was finalized three months later. This order gave Annen full custody of Chen Shun and stipulated that Shwey was only permitted to see his daughter if Annen initiated contact.
安恩苦苦哀求保命，并向施韦扔钱试图安抚他，随后带着陈顺逃离了房子。她向警方报案，一个名为“儿童、青年与家庭”的政府机构介入了此事。2006年9月29日，法院对施韦发出了临时保护令，并在三个月后敲定了永久保护令。这项保护令赋予了安恩对陈顺的完全抚养权，并规定施韦只有在安恩主动联系的情况下才能见到女儿。
He was also required to complete a course to help him stop his violent behavior. Annen and Chen Shun sought safety at a women's refuge, where they stayed for around one month. Another woman who had been at the refuge recalled how Annen had arrived blackened and bruised with nowhere else to go. Shwey frequently flouted the protection order by driving near the refuge and attempting to contact Annen. She grew so fearful of her husband that she brought a scheduled trip to China forward by three weeks.
他还被要求完成一门旨在帮助他制止暴力行为的课程。安恩和陈顺在一家妇女庇护所寻求安全，在那里待了大约一个月。另一位曾在庇护所待过的女性回忆说，安恩当时浑身青紫、伤痕累累地到达，无处可去。施韦频繁无视保护令，开车在庇护所附近徘徊并试图联系安恩。她对丈夫感到如此恐惧，以至于将预定的中国之行提前了三周。
She even contacted the airline to request they not reveal her plans to Shwey. Two days later, Shwey had called the airline demanding to know Annen's flight details, but failed to obtain them. Annen and Chen Shun stayed in China for three months. The two had previously visited family there on several occasions, but Shwey had never joined them. He was only one year younger than Annen's mother, which was considered shameful. Being a private and reserved person, Annen didn't confide in her relatives about the
她甚至联系航空公司要求不要向施韦透露她的计划。两天后，施韦打电话给航空公司，要求了解安恩的航班详情，但未能如愿。安恩和陈顺在中国待了三个月。两人以前曾多次去那里探亲，但施韦从未与他们同行。他只比安恩的母亲小一岁，这被认为是件丢脸的事。作为一个性格内向、保守的人，安恩没有向亲戚们吐露她
abuse she was suffering. On February 26, 2007, she and Chen Shun returned to New Zealand and resumed occasional contact with Shwey. Shwey was eager to improve his reputation after rumors had spread about his martial arts career, and in early 2007, he acquired ownership of a Chinese-language newspaper called Chinese Times. Annen was a talented writer, and Shwey offered her a role as a reporter, with some acquaintances speculating that he used the publication to lure Annen back into his life.
正在遭受的虐待。2007年2月26日，她和陈顺返回新西兰，并恢复了与施韦的偶有联系。由于关于他武术生涯的谣言四起，施韦急于改善自己的名誉。2007年初，他收购了一家名为《中文先驱报》的中文报纸。安恩是一位有才华的作家，施韦为她提供了一份记者职位，一些熟人推测他是利用这份出版物诱使安恩重新回到他的生活中的。
Shwey attempted to restyle himself as an important media figure in Auckland's Chinese community, but his newspaper struggled to generate income and wasn't particularly successful. He prioritized advertising revenue over quality journalism, and continually lowered the cost of placing ads in his paper in order to attract more clients. On June 20, 2007, nine months after the attack on his family, Shwey finally fronted the Family Violence Court in Auckland. He pleaded guilty to charges of assault against Annen and Chen Shun, and to using threatening words against Annen.
施韦试图把自己重新包装成奥克兰华人社区的重要媒体人物，但他的报纸难以产生收入，并不是特别成功。他将广告收入置于优质新闻之上，并不断降低在报纸上刊登广告的成本以吸引更多客户。2007年6月20日，即对家人的袭击事件发生九个月后，施韦终于在奥克兰的家庭暴力法庭出庭。他对针对安恩和陈顺的袭击指控以及对安恩使用威胁性语言的指控表示认罪。
The probation service recommended that Shwey be jailed, but Judge Phil Recordon ordered a one-year suspended sentence instead, thus releasing Shwey back home. Annen and Chen Shun were provided with no further protection or support. Earlier that month, Annen and Chen Shun flew to New Zealand's capital city of Wellington, located 642 kilometres south of Auckland. While Annen's reasons for doing so aren't entirely known, it has been speculated that she was attempting to escape her husband. Once in Wellington, the mother and daughter bordered at the home of a truck driver named
缓刑服务部门建议判处施韦监禁，但法官菲尔·雷科登（Phil Recordon）却下令判处一年缓刑，从而将施韦释放回家。安恩和陈顺没有得到进一步的保护或支持。当月早些时候，安恩和陈顺飞往新西兰首都惠灵顿，该市位于奥克兰以南642公里处。虽然安恩这样做的原因不完全为人所知，但据推测她是在试图逃离丈夫。一到惠灵顿，这对母女就寄宿在一名名叫
Wei Hong Song. Being miserable and isolated, Annen began keeping a blog as a way to express her feelings. The first entry was dated July 12, 2007 and was written in Mandarin. An excerpt read, Can't find someone to love, and can't find someone to love me. What meaning is there to go on living? To live is to continue suffering. Eager to find love, Annen signed up to several dating websites.
卫红宋（音译，Wei Hong Song）的卡车司机家中。由于痛苦和孤立，安恩开始写博客作为表达自己感受的一种方式。第一篇博文的日期是2007年7月12日，用普通话书写。其中一段摘录写道：“找不到相爱的人，也找不到爱我的人。活着还有什么意义？活着就是继续受苦。”渴望找到爱情的安恩注册了几个交友网站。
In her profiles, she stated she was seeking friendship and true love in what she called a hard, uncontrollable and lonely life. She soon commenced a two-month fling with a 39-year-old married artist whose wife was away. On August 18, 2007, the relationship ended when the man's wife returned. Annen later wrote about her heartbreak on her blog, saying, I have to escape from this love, because if I can't get the whole thing, I'd rather have nothing.
在她的个人资料中，她声称自己正在她所谓的“艰难、无法控制且孤独的生活”中寻求友谊和真爱。她很快与一位39岁、妻子不在身边的已婚艺术家开始了一段为期两个月的露水情缘。2007年8月18日，随着该男子的妻子归来，这段关系宣告结束。安恩后来在博客中写下了她的心碎，她说：“我必须逃离这段爱情，因为如果我得不到全部，我宁愿什么都没有。”
It's really painful for me. I cried. But there is a kind of love called letting go, letting go forever. I don't want to hurt another innocent. That's why I'd rather hurt myself. At one point, Shuei arrived in Wellington unannounced, having pursued his wife and daughter all the way from Auckland. And with a torch and a small axe, he broke into the house they were staying at.
“这对我来说真的很痛苦。我哭了。但有一种爱叫作放手，永远地放手。我不想伤害另一个无辜的人。这就是为什么我宁愿伤害自己。”有一次，施韦未经预告便抵达惠灵顿，他一路从奥克兰追踪妻子和女儿来到这里。带着一把手电筒和小斧头，他闯入了她们寄宿的房子。
Annen and Chen Shun weren't home at the time, but the owner, Wei Hong Song, was. Wei Hong grabbed a gun and managed to chase Shuei from his home. Later, Shuei told a friend that he had intended to force Annen back to Auckland and that she was lucky he hadn't found her, as he might have killed her if he did. Fearing Shuei would be able to find her and Chen Shun wherever they went, Annen thought it might be safer if they simply all lived under the same roof. In August 2007, one month before her body was recovered, she decided to return to Auckland to resume living with Shuei.
安恩和陈顺当时不在家，但房主卫红宋在。卫红抓起一把枪，设法将施韦赶出了他的家。后来，施韦告诉一位朋友，他本打算强迫安恩回奥克兰，她很幸运他没找到她，因为如果找到了他可能会杀了她。由于担心无论走到哪里施韦都能找到她和陈顺，安恩认为如果干脆大家住在一个屋檐下可能会更安全。2007年8月，也就是她的尸体被找回前的一个月，她决定返回奥克兰，恢复与施韦同居的生活。
Investigators discovered Annen's final blog entry, which was written at around midnight on Monday, September 10, 2007. It read, Living in this world, a lot of the time we live in difficulty and loneliness. If the conclusion of happiness must always be pain, I would rather I am lonely and help less. If a happy start has to end with pain, I rather I never had happiness. Therefore, I won't need to remember those happy moments and those painful experiences.
调查人员发现了安恩的最后一篇博客文章，写于2007年9月10日星期一午夜左右。上面写着：“生活在这个世界上，很多时候我们都生活在艰难和孤独中。如果幸福的结局注定是痛苦，我宁愿我孤独且无依无靠。如果一个幸福的开始必须以痛苦告终，我宁愿我从未拥有过幸福。因此，我不需要去记住那些快乐的时刻和痛苦的经历。”
Investigators pieced together Annen's last known movements and discovered that her neighbors recalled last seeing her between 4 and 5pm on Tuesday, September 11. At 6.45pm that same evening, she was witnessed buying groceries at a nearby supermarket, marking the final time anyone outside of her family saw her alive. The following day of Wednesday, September 12, Shuei's newspaper, Chinese Times, was scheduled to run an edition, but Shuei made excuses to his employees as to why they couldn't publish. That same day, he ate lunch at a restaurant called Loverdark, where owner Raymond Tang
调查人员拼凑出安恩最后已知的行踪，发现她的邻居最后一次看到她是在9月11日星期二下午4点到5点之间。当天傍晚6点45分钟，有人目击她在附近的一家超市买菜，这也是任何家庭成员以外的人最后一次看到她活著。第二天，即9月12日星期三，施韦的报纸《中文先驱报》原本计划出一期，但施韦对员工百般推脱，解释为什么他们无法出版。当天，他在一家名为“Loverdark”的餐厅吃午饭，店主雷蒙德·唐（Raymond Tang）
noted that Shuei appeared calm throughout his meal. Annen's mother, Xiaoping Liu, had been calling her daughter's mobile phone since the day prior, but with no response. At some point during Wednesday, Shuei finally answered. They explained that Annen and Chen Shun had gone to Wellington and would be back on Sunday, September 16. Just before 9am on Thursday, September 13, Shuei left his house with Chen Shun and drove Annen's car approximately 10km northwest to the Henderson police station.
注意到施韦在用餐期间显得很平静。安恩的母亲刘晓平（音译，Xiaoping Liu）自前一天起就一直在拨打女儿的手机，但无人接听。周三的某个时候，施韦终于接了电话。他们解释说安恩和陈顺去了惠灵顿，将于9月16日星期日回来。9月13日星期四上午9点前不久，施韦带着陈顺离开家，开着安恩的车向西北行驶了大约10公里来到亨德森（Henderson）警察局。
There, his passport and a ceremonial Tai Chi sword were being held pending the outcome of his assault charges. As Shuei had since been given a suspended sentence, he was able to reclaim these possessions. At 11am, Shuei visited a travel agency and purchased a return flight to Melbourne for himself. He then withdrew $6,445 in cash and emptied his safety deposit box. Once again, he ate lunch at Loverdark before returning to the travel agency and purchasing a return flight to Melbourne for Chen Shun.
在那里，由于他的袭击指控结果未决，他的护照和一把仪仗太极剑一直被扣押。由于施韦此后被判处缓刑，他得以索回这些财产。上午11点，施韦拜访了一家旅行社，为自己购买了飞往墨尔本的往返机票。然后他提取了6,445美元的现金，并清空了他的保险箱。他再次在Loverdark吃午饭，然后返回旅行社，为陈顺购买了飞往墨尔本的往返机票。
That afternoon, Shuei drove himself and Chen Shun to Auckland's International Airport in Annen's car. Investigators obtained CCTV footage which had captured the father and daughter as they checked in and went through customs. They had arrived in Melbourne at 7.40pm on Thursday, September 13, more than 48 hours after Annen was last seen alive. At the time, the protection order issued against Shuei was still in place, meaning he wasn't permitted to have custody of Chen Shun.
那天下午，施韦开着安恩的车带着陈顺前往奥克兰国际机场。调查人员获取了闭路电视监控录像，拍下了这对父女办理登机手续并通过海关的画面。他们于9月13日星期四晚上7点40分抵达墨尔本，比安恩最后一次被看到活著的时间晚了48个多小时。当时，针对施韦发出的保护令依然有效，这意味着他不被允许拥有陈顺的抚养权。
According to the officer in charge of Auckland Airport, Inspector Richard Middleton, a stringent system was in place to prevent an individual involved in a court custody order from leaving the country with the child. However, no such alert appeared when Shuei left New Zealand with Chen Shun. Staff from the police, customs and Ministry of Justice were unable to explain how Shuei was able to exit the country with his daughter. Grace, Shuei's 26-year-old daughter from his first marriage, was still living in Auckland, less than two kilometres from her father's home.
据奥克兰机场负责人、督察理查德·米德尔顿（Richard Middleton）称，当时实行了一套严格的系统，以防止涉及法院抚养权令的个人带着孩子离开该国。然而，当施韦带着陈顺离开新西兰时，并没有出现这样的警报。来自警察、海关和司法部的员工无法解释施韦是如何带着女儿离开这个国家的。格蕾丝是施韦与第一任妻子所生的26岁女儿，当时仍住在奥克兰，距离她父亲的家不到两公里。
She maintained no contact with him, as Shuei's claim that Grace had run away after he sponsored her to move to New Zealand was false. The truth was that two months after her arrival, Shuei had travelled to Los Angeles, leaving the then 19-year-old alone to fend for herself in a foreign country where she couldn't speak the language. Grace had begged her father for financial support, but he had refused. To get by, she managed to find work in fast food restaurants before eventually meeting a New Zealander named Shane and completing a financial degree at the University of Auckland.
她与他保持着零联系，因为施韦声称格蕾丝在他资助她搬到新西兰后逃跑的说法是假的。事实是，在她抵达两个月后，施韦前往了洛杉矶，留下当时19岁的她在一个不会说当地语言的外国独自自谋生路。格蕾丝曾向父亲请求经济支持，但他拒绝了。为了勉强糊口，她设法在快餐店找到了工作，最后遇到了一名名叫肖恩（Shane）的新西兰人，并在奥克兰大学完成了金融学位。
She and Shane then married and had a baby boy. In July of 2007, Grace and Shane had seen Shuei at a local restaurant but promptly left without speaking to him. It wasn't until she saw the news reports that her father was wanted on suspicion of murdering his wife and abandoning his young child that Grace even knew she had a half-sister. Feeling heartbroken by this news, she issued a public plea, asking for her father to return to New Zealand. She told reporters that Shuei could be kind when things were going well, but that, quote,
她随后与肖恩结婚并育有一个男孩。2007年7月，格蕾丝和肖恩在当地一家餐馆见过水运生，但很快便离开，没有和他说过话。直到格蕾丝看到新闻报道称她的父亲因涉嫌谋杀妻子并遗弃幼子而遭到通缉，她才知道自己还有一个同父异母的妹妹。听到这个消息，她心如刀割，公开呼吁并恳求父亲返回新西兰。她告诉记者，水运生在一切顺利时可能会表现得很友善，但引用她的话说，
difficult times reveal the character of the person, and Shuei is somebody that you don't want to upset. To help provide financial assistance for her half-sister, Grace established a trust for Chen Shun, called the Little Pumpkin Trust. She told reporters that she and her husband were considering adopting Chen Shun, but they also understood that Annen's parents may want to take their granddaughter home to China. In Melbourne, the Victorian Department of Human Services made a joint decision with its New Zealand counterpart, child youth and family, to repatriate Chen Shun to Walkland.
困难时期才能显露出一个人的品性，而水运生是个你绝对不想去招惹的人。为了向同父异母的妹妹提供经济援助，格蕾丝为陈顺设立了一个名为“小南瓜信托”的信托基金。她告诉记者，她和丈夫正在考虑收养陈顺，但他们也理解安楠的父母可能想把孙女带回中国。在墨尔本，维多利亚州人类服务部与新西兰的对口部门儿童、青年和家庭局做出联合决定，将陈顺遣返至怀塔克雷。
As soon as her grandmother, Xiaoping Liu, had been informed of Annen's death, she immediately made plans to travel to New Zealand to collect her granddaughter. On September 25, 10 days after Chen Shun was abandoned, the two were reunited in Auckland, where photographers captured the moment the pair wrapped in a tight embrace. Speaking via an interpreter, Xiaoping told ABC Radio that she wanted to take her granddaughter back to China, stating, She has got nobody apart from me. Annen was my only child, and she is my only granddaughter.
安楠的母亲刘晓萍一得知女儿的死讯，立刻就计划前往新西兰接回孙女。9月25日，即陈顺被遗弃10天后，两人在奥克兰团聚，摄影师捕捉到了两人紧紧相拥的感人瞬间。刘晓萍通过翻译告诉美国广播公司电台，她想把孙女带回中国，并表示：“她除了我之外别无亲人。安楠是我的独生女，而她是我唯一的孙女。”
I will do my utmost to bring her up. She has called me grandma since she was very young. She has lived in my home in Hunan. Everyone in my family loves her. A New Zealand judge ordered that Xiaoping be given leave to apply for a parenting order. She also ruled that Grace be permitted to have contact with her half-sister by telephone, email and visits when possible. The government paid approximately $10,000 in legal fees for Xiaoping to gain custody
我会尽我最大的努力把她抚养大。她很小的时候就叫我奶奶了。她一直住在我在湖南的家里。我家里每个人都很疼她。新西兰法官下令批准刘晓萍申请抚养令。法官还裁定，允许格蕾丝在可能的情况下通过电话、电子邮件和探视与同父异母的妹妹保持联系。政府为刘晓萍支付了大约1万美元的法律费用以取得
of Chen Shun, and also covered the costs of Annen's funeral. While Xiaoping and Chen Shun waited for the legal process to clear, Auckland police attempted to entertain them by taking them to visit a vineyard and see a butterfly show. On October 7, 2007, after spending 12 days in New Zealand, Xiaoping and Chen Shun returned to China with Annen's ashes. In an open letter, Xiaoping expressed her gratitude to New Zealand's police, government and the public for their support and kindness. Meanwhile, Naiyin Shui had been labelled a fugitive, and authorities in both New Zealand
陈顺的抚养权，并承担了安楠的葬礼费用。在刘晓萍和陈顺等待法律程序审批期间，奥克兰警方试图通过带他们参观葡萄园和观赏蝴蝶展来让他们散心。2007年10月7日，在新西兰度过了12天后，刘晓萍和陈顺带着安楠的骨灰返回了中国。在一封公开信中，刘晓萍向新西兰警方、政府和公众的支持与善意表达了感激之情。与此同时，耐茵·水（Naiyin Shui）已被贴上了逃犯的标签，新西兰和美国的
and the United States were on alert. Customs records revealed he had entered Los Angeles on September 15 under the Visa Waiver Program, which permitted citizens of New Zealand to visit the United States for 90 days without a visa. After the discovery of Annen's body, a warrant for Shui's arrest had been forwarded to Interpol's United States office, and a red notice was issued. A task force was formed that included the U.S. Marshals Service, the Federal Bureau of Investigation, Immigration Officers, the Los Angeles Police Department, and New Zealand Police.
当局都处于高度戒备状态。海关记录显示，他于9月15日根据免签证计划进入洛杉矶，该计划允许新西兰公民无需签证访问美国90天。在发现安楠的尸体后，针对水的逮捕令已被转发给国际刑警组织美国办事处，并发布了红色通缉令。一个由美国法警局、联邦调查局、移民官员、洛杉矶警察局和新西兰警察局组成的工作组随即成立。
Investigators soon discovered that upon Shui's arrival to the United States, he had briefly stayed at a cheap motel in Los Angeles' Chinatown district. But after that, the trail went cold. On September 25, the U.S. Marshals Service published a wanted poster with Shui's details that appealed to the American public to report any information regarding his whereabouts. The poster indicated that Shui was 53 years old, with black hair and brown eyes, standing at 5 feet 7 inches tall and weighing 200 pounds. It was warned that he should be considered armed and dangerous, and could be hiding anywhere
调查人员很快发现，水抵达美国后，曾在洛杉矶唐人街的一家廉价汽车旅馆短暂住过。但在此之后，线索就断了。9月25日，美国法警局发布了一张带有水的信息的通缉令，呼吁美国公众举报任何关于他下落的信息。通缉令显示，水现年53岁，黑发棕眼，身高5英尺7英寸（约1.7米），体重200磅（约90公斤）。通缉令警告称，应当认为他持有武器且极度危险，并可能藏匿在
in the country. A reward of US$10,000 was also offered by the New Zealand Police for information leading to an arrest. A press conference was held at the U.S. Marshals Command Center in Los Angeles, with the journalists from New Zealand, Australia, and Chinese-American newspapers in attendance, as well as news crews from L.A. television stations. By this time, Shui had been on the run for 10 days. U.S. Marshals and commander of the regional task force, Tom Hesseon, told of those assembled
全国的任何地方。新西兰警方还悬赏1万美元，以征集能促成逮捕的信息。美国法警驻洛杉矶指挥中心举行了一场新闻发布会，新西兰、澳大利亚和美籍华人报纸的记者以及洛杉矶电视台的新闻摄制组均出席了会议。此时，水已经潜逃了10天。美国法警兼地区特遣部队指挥官汤姆·海森（Tom Hesseon）向在场的人员
that there was nothing to indicate that Shui had left Los Angeles. He stated, quote, He's in our country. We want to get him, and we're going to send him back to New Zealand. One journalist asked why the Interpol red notice had been issued only after Anand's body was identified, which was four days after Shui had fled to Los Angeles. New Zealand's police liaison officer, Superintendent Neville Matthews, responded, What I can say to you is it was expedited extremely quickly, much more quickly than
透露，没有迹象表明水已经离开洛杉矶。他说道：“他在我们国家。我们要抓到他，我们要把他送回新西兰。”一名记者问及，为什么国际刑警组织的红色通缉令是在安楠的尸体被确认身份（即水潜逃至洛杉矶四天后）才发出的。新西兰警方联络官内维尔·马修斯（Neville Matthews）警司回应称：“我能对你们说的是，这件事推进得极其迅速，比我们过去的做法要快得多。”
we have done in the past. When the journalist continued to probe, Chief Hesseon asked, Frankly, sir, are you just trying to bash the officers? Chief Hesseon said he was confident that U.S. authorities would capture Shui. He cautioned civilians against taking matters into their own hands if they spotted the fugitive, stating, quote, We do not know his state of mind. We do not know whether he is extremely violent or whether he has armed himself in some way.
当记者继续追问时，海森长官反问道：“坦白说，先生，你是在故意抨击警务人员吗？”海森长官表示，他确信美国当局会抓获水。他警告平民如果发现逃犯，切勿擅自行动，并表示：“我们不知道他的精神状态。我们不知道他是否极端暴力，或者是否以某种方式武装了自己。”
I don't want to see anybody get hurt. Over the following months, several confirmed sightings of Shui came through. In October 2007, he was spotted in the Texas City of Houston, driving a 1996 Blue Ford Thunderbird with Texas license plates. Investigators were unable to locate him, but they told reporters they believed he may have been living in Texas for approximately one month. The following month, a segment about the case was broadcast on the television program America's Most Wanted, which prompted more tip-offs.
“我不想看到任何人受伤。”在随后的几个月里，陆续有关于水行踪的确切目击报告传来。2007年10月，他被发现在德克萨斯州休斯敦市驾驶着一辆挂有德州车牌的1966年产蓝色福特雷鸟（Ford Thunderbird）轿车。调查人员未能找到他，但他们告诉记者，他们认为水可能已经在德州生活了大约一个月。第二个月，一档名为《美国通缉令》（America's Most Wanted）的电视节目播出了关于此案的一个片段，从而引发了更多的举报。
Two months later, on January 23, 2008, Shui was sighted driving the same Ford Thunderbird, this time in the Mississippi City of Biloxi, approximately 414 miles east of Houston. Despite these sightings, Shui continued to evade authorities. In February 2008, 400 miles northeast of Biloxi, in the Georgia City of Shambli, a group of six Chinese Americans befriended a newcomer who was looking to settle down locally. The man had introduced himself as Mr. Tang, a masseur who was eager to set up a massage business nearby. He was sharing a room with one of the individuals, a man named Geisen Wu.
两个月后的2008年1月23日，有人目击水再次驾驶着那辆福特雷鸟轿车，这一次是在密西西比州的比洛克西市，位于休斯敦以东约414英里处。尽管有这些目击报告，水依然继续逃避着当局的追捕。2008年2月，在比洛克西东北方向400英里处、佐治亚州的尚布利（Chamblei）市，六名美国华裔结识了一位想要在当地安家落户的新来者。这名男子自我介绍叫唐先生，是一名急于在附近开一家按摩店的按摩师。他和其中一个人——一个名叫吴盖森（Geisen Wu）的男子——合住一个房间。
Geisen liked Mr. Tang as he appeared to be friendly, although he often talked and cried throughout the night. On Saturday, February 23, Mr. Tang offered to show his new group of friends some kung-fu poses and one that he demonstrated caught their attention. A photograph of a man performing the same pose had recently been published in the American Chinese newspaper, World Journal, alongside an article about fugitive Na Ying Shui. The group suddenly realized that Mr. Tang bore a striking resemblance to the wanted man, the only difference being that he appeared to have recently had a haircut.
盖森挺喜欢唐先生的，因为他看起来很友好，尽管他经常在夜里自言自语并哭泣。2月23日星期六，唐先生主动提出向他的新朋友们展示一些功夫动作，他演示的一个动作引起了他们的注意。美籍中文报纸《世界日报》最近刚好刊登了一张一名男子做着同样动作的照片，照片旁是一篇关于逃犯那英水（Na Ying Shui）的文章。这群人突然意识到，唐先生与通缉犯长得惊人地相似，唯一的区别似乎是他最近刚理过发。
Realizing to their suspicions was the fact that Mr. Tang had recently changed the license plates on his car from Texas tags to New York ones, despite not ever leaving the state of Georgia. Realizing that Mr. Tang was in fact Na Ying Shui, the group called the local police station and attempted to explain the matter. However, as they spoke little English, the officers were unable to understand them. After multiple failed efforts to report Shui, the group concocted a plan to capture the fugitive themselves.
让他们怀疑的另一个事实是，唐先生最近把车上的车牌从德州车牌换成了纽约车牌，尽管他从未离开过佐治亚州。意识到唐先生实际上就是那英水后，这群人拨打了当地警察局的电话，并试图说明情况。然而，由于他们英语说得很少，警官们根本听不懂他们在说什么。在多次举报水失败后，这群人策划了一个亲自抓捕逃犯的计划。
They initially considered alluring him to a restaurant under the pretense of sharing a meal, but concluded that inviting him to a private residence would be better. The group told Shui they were having a party on Thursday, February 28, and then started planning how to take down the martial arts expert. When the day arrived, Shui entered the apartment, unaware of what was about to take place. One of the men was a skilled footballer, and he swiftly kicked Shui while the remaining five friends tackled him to the ground. Shui struggled violently and attempted to strike his attackers with his elbow, but they
他们最初考虑以聚餐为借口将他诱至餐馆，但后来断定邀请他到私人住所会更好。这群人告诉水，他们将在2月28日星期四举办一个派对，随后开始策划如何制服这位武术高手。当日子到来时，水走进了公寓，全然不知即将发生什么。其中一名男子是个足球健将，他迅速飞踹了水，其余五名朋友则一拥而上将他扑倒在地。水剧烈挣扎并试图用手肘击打袭击者，但他们
managed to remove Shui's pants and used them to hog-tie his legs and arms together. The five men of the group sat on Shui while the one woman, Ms. Chan, called the police. When officers arrived at the scene, the group showed them the newspaper article about Na Ying Shui and relinquished their hold on him. Although Shui was having some trouble breathing, he was otherwise unharmed. The attending officers searched the restrained suspect and discovered his New Zealand driver's license, as well as six and a half thousand US dollars in cash. He was promptly placed under arrest and taken into custody at the Shambli police station.
设法脱下水的裤子，并用裤子将他的双腿和双臂绑在了一起。这群人中的五个男人坐在水身上，而唯一的女性陈女士则打电话报警。当警官赶到现场时，这群人向他们展示了关于那英水的报纸文章，并松开了对他的控制。尽管水呼吸有些困难，但除此之外他安然无恙。到场的警官搜查了被制服的嫌疑人，发现了他的新西兰驾照，以及6500美元现金。他随即被捕，并被羁押到尚布利警察局。
In a subsequent press conference, chief of Shambli police Mark Johnson told the media that although Shui was somewhat dirty and smelly, he appeared to be in good health. Chief Johnson added, quote, It's not a pretty picture for the martial arts expert. He ended up with these pants around his ankles and tied up. The police praised the group for their successful citizen's arrest and noted that they would be nominated for an award for their bravery. One of the individuals involved with the arrest told the press, quote,
在随后的新闻发布会上，尚布利警察局局长马克·约翰逊（Mark Johnson）向媒体表示，尽管水身上有些脏且有异味，但他的身体状况似乎很好。约翰逊局长补充道：“这位武术高手的下场可真不美观。他最后落得个裤子褪到脚踝、五花大绑的下场。”警方对这群人成功的公民抓捕行为表示赞赏，并指出他们将被提名表彰其勇敢行为。参与抓捕的一名成员对媒体表示，
I am not a hero. As a Chinese person living overseas, I feel I have the responsibility to help catch him. The arrest of an international fugitive was a significant moment for the small city of Shambli, which had just 22 police officers overseeing its population of 10,000. A spokesperson for the police department called it a once-in-a-lifetime event and said his officers were, quote, pumped about it. The relevant agencies were informed of the arrest and Shui was later transferred to the nearby DeKalb County Jail to await deportation.
“我不是英雄。作为一名在海外生活的中国人，我觉得我有责任协助抓捕他。”抓获国际逃犯对尚布利这个仅有22名警察管理1万人口的小城市来说是一个重大时刻。警察局的一位发言人称这是一生难得的事件，并表示他的警官们对此感到“兴奋不已”。有关机构得到了逮捕的通知，水随后被转移到附近的迪卡尔布县监狱等待引渡。
As he had already overstayed the 90-day visit permitted under the visa waiver program, he could be deported back to New Zealand without the need for a lengthy and drawn-out extradition process. A little over a week after his capture, US authorities escorted Shui, who was manacled by the wrists and ankles, on a flight back to Auckland. He arrived on Monday, March 10, 2008, and appeared before a judge the same day. Nine-inch Shui was charged with the murder of his wife Anand Leo, and bail was denied. Detective Senior Sergeant Simon Scott told reporters, quote,
由于他已经滞留超过了免签证计划允许的90天访问期，他可以被直接遣返回新西兰，而无需经历漫长而拖沓的引渡程序。在他被捕一周多后，美国当局给水戴上手铐和脚镣，护送他登上返回奥克兰的航班。他于2008年3月10日星期一抵达，并于同日出庭受审。耐茵·水被指控谋杀他的妻子安楠（Anand Liu），且不得保释。高级侦探警长西蒙·斯科特（Simon Scott）告诉记者：
We're just happy to have him back in New Zealand. Over the next few weeks and months, we'll look at the evidence and consider further charges in due course. A preliminary hearing to determine whether there was enough evidence to send Shui to trial was scheduled for September. In the lead-up, Shui's barrister, Chris Komiski, revealed that his client intended to argue that he was being framed. According to Shui, a man Anand had met several weeks prior to her death was responsible for
“我们很高兴能把他带回新西兰。在接下来的几周和几个月里，我们将审查证据，并在适当时机考虑提出进一步指控。”旨在确定是否有足够证据将水交付审判的初步听证会定于9月举行。在此之前，水的辩护律师克里斯·科米斯基（Chris Komiski）透露，他的客户端打算辩称自己遭到了陷害。据水供述，安楠在死前几周结识的一名男子才是谋杀的罪魁祸首，
the murder, and had then hid her body in Shui's car to pass the blame. Upon learning of the man's plot, Shui had panicked and fled the country with Chen Shun. Mr Komiski stated that he would be hiring a private investigator to track down the individual for questioning. On September 3, 2008, Shui's preliminary hearing began in Auckland's District Court. The prosecution presented evidence that after a series of steadily escalating violent incidents, Anand had died of ligature strangulation at the hands of her husband. Shui openly wept as the pathologist had detailed how Anand's body had been found in the boot
该男子随后将安楠的尸体藏在水的车里以嫁祸于人。在得知该男子的阴谋后，水感到惊慌失措，于是带着陈顺逃离了该国。科米斯基先生表示，他将聘请一名私家侦探追踪该男子的下落以进行讯问。2008年9月3日，水的初步听证会在奥克兰地区法院开始审理。控方出示证据称，在经历了一系列不断升级的暴力事件后，安楠死于其丈夫实施的勒颈窒息。当病理学家详细描述安楠的尸体如何在水的汽车后备箱里被发现、
of Shui's car with a yellow tie wrapped around her neck. Six other witnesses also gave evidence, but due to strict restrictions regarding media coverage of the hearing, their testimonies were not made public. After two days, the two justices of the peace presiding over the hearing determined there was enough evidence to send Nayan Shui to trial for the death of his wife. He was ordered to remain in custody until his trial in Auckland's High Court. The trial began nine months later on June 1, 2009, in front of an all-female jury with Justice Hugh Williams presiding.
脖子上缠着一条黄色领带时，水公开痛哭起来。另外六名证人也出庭作证，但由于对听证会媒体报道的严格限制，他们的证词并未公之于众。两天后，主持听证会的两名太平绅士裁定，有足够证据将那英水以谋杀妻子罪交付审判。他被下令继续还押候审，直至其在奥克兰高等法院的审判。审判于九个月后的2009年6月1日开始，由全女性陪审团审理，法官休·威廉姆斯（Hugh Williams）主持。
Prosecutor Aaron Perkins informed the court that Shui's marriage to Anand had not only been loveless and cold, but was also marred by abuse and violence. He called 95 witnesses to the stand as part of his case, including Anand's mother Shaoping, who gave evidence from China via video link and a translator. Clearly grief-stricken, Shaoping explained that she had never met her son-in-law in person and had only spoken to him twice over the phone. Around September 11, 2007, the last day Anand was seen alive, Shaoping had tried calling her daughter's mobile phone repeatedly because she hadn't heard from her and had a, quote,
检察官亚伦·帕金斯（Aaron Perkins）向法庭陈述称，水和安楠的婚姻不仅没有爱意且十分冷漠，还充斥着虐待与暴力。他传唤了95名证人出庭作证，其中包括安楠的母亲刘晓萍，她通过视频连线和翻译从中国作证。刘晓萍显然悲痛欲绝，她解释说自己从未亲自见过女婿，仅通过电话和他交谈过两次。大约在2007年9月11日（即安楠生前最后一次露面那天），刘晓萍曾多次试图拨打女儿的手机，因为她一直联系不上女儿，并且有一种，
bad feeling. Shui had eventually answered the phone the following day and told Shaoping that Anand had gone to Wellington with Chen Shun. Although Shaoping had been suspicious of Shui, his answer placated her and she felt somewhat reassured. At the conclusion of her testimony, Judge Williams inquired after the well-being of Chen Shun. Shaoping gave a heated and tearful response in Mandarin, which was not translated for the court as it was deemed too controversial.
不好的预感。水最终在第二天接听了电话，并告诉刘晓萍安楠带着陈顺去了惠灵顿。尽管刘晓萍对水心存疑虑，但他的回答平息了她的疑虑，让她感到有些安心。在证词结束时，威廉姆斯法官询问了陈顺的近况。刘晓萍用普通话做出了激动且泪流满面的回应，由于被认为过于具有争议性，法庭并未对此进行翻译。
The court was presented with the CCTV footage recorded at Southern Cross Station, which showed Shui abandoning Chen Shun before making his way to Melbourne Airport. Evidence was also presented about the discovery of Anand's body as well as her injuries and cause of death, with Mr Perkins contending that Shui had strangled his wife with his own tie before dumping her body in the boot of his vehicle. However, as no blood or sign of a struggle had been found anywhere in the couple's home, Mr Perkins acknowledged that investigators had been unable to find evidence as to where Anand had been murdered.
法庭出示了南部十字车站（Southern Cross Station）录制的闭路电视录像，画面显示水在前往墨尔本机场之前遗弃了陈顺。法庭还出示了关于发现安楠尸体以及她的伤势和死因的证据，帕金斯先生断言，水用自己的领带勒死了妻子，然后将尸体扔进汽车后备箱。然而，由于在夫妻俩的家中没有找到任何血迹或搏斗痕迹，帕金斯先生承认调查人员未能找到安楠被谋杀地点的证据。
Forensic scientist Salianne Harbison told the court that Anand's underwear, which was also recovered from the boot, contained the DNA of three males. The major components correspond to Shui's DNA, with the minor trace components present from at least two further male individuals. Shui's DNA was also found on the tie, along with DNA from one of the mystery men. Ms Harbison confirmed that DNA could survive a washing machine cycle that clarified that quote, it is unusual and it would be surprising to find so many contributors. Once again, the defence presented Shui's claims that another man was responsible for
法医科学家萨利安·哈比森（Salianne Harbison）在法庭上表示，从后备箱中取回的安楠内裤上含有三名男子的DNA。主要成分与水的DNA相符，微量成分则来自至少另外两名男性个体。在领带上也发现了水的DNA，以及其中一名神秘男子的DNA。哈比森女士证实DNA可以在洗衣机洗涤循环中存活，并澄清说，“这很不寻常，发现这么多的贡献者令人惊讶。”辩方再次提出了水的说法，即另一名男子应对
Anand's death, which they argued was the result of quote, rough sex gone wrong. Shui's barrister Chris Kamiski told the court that Anand had developed feelings for Wei Hong-Sung, the truck driver she had bordered with in Wellington after escaping the violence in her home. To support his case, Mr Kamiski read aloud from an online conversation Anand had with a friend. In it, Anand said she'd never been interested in sex prior to meeting Wei Hong-Sung, but she had developed a crush on him that made her feel quote, sexually ferocious, like a wolf. Wei Hong testified that he and Anand never had a sexual relationship. Regardless, Mr Kamiski used the ambiguity of Anand's message to support Shui's defence
安楠的死负责，他们辩称这是“一场搞砸了的粗暴性爱”的结果。水的辩护律师克里斯·卡米斯基（Chris Kamiski）向法庭表示，安楠在逃离家中的暴力后，对她在惠灵顿寄宿的卡车司机韦洪松（Wei Hong-Sung）产生了感情。为了支持他的辩护，卡米斯基先生大声宣读了安楠与一位朋友的网络聊天记录。在聊天中，安楠说她在遇到韦洪松之前对性从未感兴趣过，但她对他产生了一种迷恋，让她感觉自己“对性很凶猛，就像一匹狼”。韦洪威证实他和安楠从未有过性关系。尽管如此，卡米斯基先生利用安楠信息中的模棱两可之处来支持水的辩护，
that Anand had died as a result of erotic asphyxiation, a type of sexual activity that involves cutting off an individual's air supply. Mr Kamiski asked pathologist Timothy Kohlmeier whether it was possible that Anand's death had been an accident. Mr Kohlmeier initially stated he couldn't answer that question, but then remarked, if an answer is required, I can only say it's possible. Naoyin Shui listened intently to the entirety of the trial via a translator, but did not take the stand to testify in his own defence. On Friday, June 29, more than four weeks after the trial had commenced,
即安楠死于情色窒息——这是一种涉及切断个人氧气供应的性活动。卡米斯基先生询问病理学家蒂莫西·科尔迈尔（Timothy Kohlmeier），安楠的死是否可能是一场意外。科尔迈尔最初表示他无法回答这个问题，但随后评论道：“如果非要一个答案，我只能说这是可能的。”那英水通过翻译专心聆听了整个审判过程，但并未出庭为自己作证。6月29日星期五，即审判开始四个多星期后，
the jury retired to consider their verdict. They deliberated for a day before returning to court around midday on Saturday, June 30, finding Naoyin Shui guilty of murdering Anand Liu. When the verdict was read aloud, Shui raised a fist in the air and cried out, unfair, I'm innocent, I'm innocent. He was restrained by guards, but continued his outburst by repeatedly shouting, unfair, unfair, really unfair. He struggled as two security guards escorted him from the courtroom. Sentencing took place a month later on July 31, 2009, with Shui remaining subdued throughout the proceedings. Judge Williams noted that Shui was only able to concoct his defence that another man was
陪审团退席商议裁决结果。他们审议了一天，然后于6月30日星期六中午左右返回法庭，裁定那英水谋杀安楠刘（Anand Liu）罪名成立。当裁决被宣读时，水高举拳头大喊：“不公平，我是无辜的，我是无辜的。”他被警卫制止，但仍继续大喊大叫，反复高喊“不公平，不公平，真的太不公平了”。两名保安将他带出法庭时，他还在不断挣扎。宣判于一个月后的2009年7月31日进行，水在整个庭审过程中表现得较为温顺。威廉姆斯法官指出，水之所以能够编造出另一名男子对
responsible for Anand's murder, because the prosecution was required to disclose the information about the DNA fragments from two unknown males being recovered from Anand's underwear and the tie around her neck. However, Judge Williams clarified that the amount of Shui's DNA found on those items far outweighed the smaller traces belonging to the two unknown persons. Judge Williams continued, quote, The jury must have regarded as literally incredible the suggestion that it was a mere coincidence that your wife died at about the time you made very considerable efforts to leave first New Zealand and then Australia, with as much money as possible, as quickly as possible.
安楠谋杀案负责的辩护，是因为控方必须披露关于从安楠内裤及其脖子上的领带中提取到两名未知男性DNA片段的信息。然而，威廉姆斯法官澄清说，在这些物品上发现的水的DNA数量远远超过了属于这两名未知人员的微量DNA。威廉姆斯法官接着说道：“陪审团必定认为以下说法简直不可信：你的妻子死于你竭尽全力以最快速度、携带尽可能多的钱先后离开新西兰和澳大利亚的时间点，这纯属巧合。”
The pointers to your having murdered your wife, though circumstantial, were very significant indeed. The pointers towards another man or men having murdered her were slight. Judge Williams said he had taken into account a number of aggravating factors, including Shui's previous history of violence and death threats against Anand, his efforts to evade detection by fleeing overseas, and the cruelty of the murder itself, quote. Anand was killed by strangulation. Everyone has choked on occasions and knows how frightening it is to be unable to breathe, even for only a few seconds. Here, you subjected your wife to about 45 seconds of what must have been excruciating terror, lost you were
“指向你谋杀妻子的迹象，虽属 circumstantial（间接证据），但确实非常重大。而指向另一个或另一些男人谋杀她的迹象则微乎其微。”威廉姆斯法官表示，他已将多项加重情节纳入考量，包括水此前对安楠实施暴力和死亡威胁的历史、他通过潜逃海外来逃避追捕的行为、以及谋杀本身的残酷性。法官说道：“安楠是被勒死。每个人都有过呛咳的经历，也都知道无法呼吸是多么可怕，哪怕只有短短几秒钟。在这里，你让妻子承受了大约45秒令人痛苦绝望的恐怖折磨，当时你在
grotting her until she lost consciousness. And your determination to kill her was such, you continued to apply pressure to the tie, for about another two to three minutes to ensure she died. Judge Williams also noted Shui's cruelty in abandoning his young daughter in a foreign country, but acknowledged this wouldn't impact sentencing as it wasn't included in the charges against him. He sentenced Shui to life in prison, the mandatory sentence for murder in New Zealand, but with a minimum of just 12 years before he would be eligible for parole. Shui was removed to serve his sentence at Rimitaka Prison in Upper Heart, 650 kilometers south of Auckland. Outside court, Shui's barrister Chris Kamiski told the media that his client
掐着她直到她失去意识。而你杀她的决心如此之坚决，以至于你继续对领带施压，大约又有两到三分钟以确保她死亡。”威廉姆斯法官还指出了水在异国他乡遗弃幼女的残忍行径，但承认这不会影响量刑，因为这并未被列入对他的指控中。他判处水无期徒刑，这是新西兰对谋杀罪的强制刑罚，但设定了最低服刑12年后方可获得假释的资格。水被带到奥克兰以南650公里处上哈特的里米塔卡监狱（Rimitaka Prison）服刑。在法庭外，水的辩护律师克里斯·卡米斯基告诉媒体，他的客户
maintained his innocence and would soon be lodging an appeal. He added that Shui was sorry for abandoning Chen Shun, stating, he regrets that, and he will regret that all of his life. On September 7, 2009, Shui's legal team filed for appeal on the grounds that the jury should have been sequestered throughout the trial due to the high-profile nature of the case. A provisional appeal date was scheduled for May 4, 2011, but on April 29, just five days before the hearing was set to commence, Shui's legal team filed papers abandoning the appeal for unreported reasons. Despite this, Shui continued to insist upon his innocence. New Zealand's corrections department received multiple requests from Chinese-language newspaper
坚称自己无罪，并将很快提起上诉。他补充说，水对遗弃陈顺感到抱歉，并表示：“他对此感到后悔，并且将为此后悔一生。”2009年9月7日，水的法律团队以本案备受瞩目为由、认为陪审团在整个审判期间应被隔离（sequestrated）为由提起上诉。临时上诉日期定于2011年5月4日，但在4月29日（即听证会开始前仅仅五天），水的法律团队以未披露的原因提交了放弃上诉的文件。尽管如此，水仍然坚称自己无罪。新西兰惩教部门多次收到华文报纸
The New Zealand Chinese Herald to interview Shui, but these requests were consistently denied on the grounds that any interview would likely have a negative impact on Annan's family. Regardless, in 2010, a reporter informed the corrections department that the publication had received a 10-page document authored by Shui. Two years later, in 2012, a book based on this document was published by the New Zealand Chinese Herald, titled, I Was Not The Murderer. In the book, Shui argued for his innocence, with one excerpt reading, The whole world has accused me of being a murderer, but I dare not even kill a chicken, not to mention kill my wife. Given that the document wasn't the result of an unauthorized
《新西兰中文先驱报》采访水的请求，但这些请求均遭到拒绝，理由是任何采访都可能对安楠的家属产生负面影响。尽管如此，在2010年，一名记者通知惩教部门，该报纸收到了一份由水撰写的10页文件。两年后的2012年，《新西兰中文先驱报》出版了一本基于该文件的书，书名为《我不是凶手》。在书中，水为自己的无罪进行了辩解，其中一段摘文写道：“全世界都指责我是个杀人犯，但我连杀一只鸡都不敢，更不用说杀我的妻子了。”鉴于该文件并非未经授权的
interview, the corrections department was unable to prohibit its publication, and the book was sold in a number of Chinese supermarkets throughout Auckland. The only action that the corrections department could take was to urge the New Zealand Chinese Herald to consider the effect the publication might have on the victim's family. On March 9, 2020, almost 12 and a half years after Annan's murder, Nain Shui's parole hearing was held at the Spring Hill Corrections Facility. Using a translator, Shui finally admitted to being guilty of killing his wife. He shared that during his time in prison, he had become an avid painter and a devout Christian.
采访产物，惩教部门无法禁止其出版，该书在奥克兰的许多华人超市均有销售。惩教部门能采取的唯一行动是敦促《新西兰中文先驱报》考虑该出版物可能对受害者家属造成的影响。2020年3月9日，在安楠被谋杀近十二年半之后，耐茵·水的假释听证会在斯普林希尔惩教所（Spring Hill Corrections Facility）举行。通过翻译，水终于承认自己犯下了杀害妻子的罪行。他分享说，在狱中期间，他成为了一名狂热的画家和虔诚的基督徒。
His prison record revealed he was well behaved and appeared to adhere to rules and regulations. When the parole board asked Shui how he had addressed his propensity for violence, he responded, Firstly, I'm very remorseful. I would like to apologize to everyone who has been hurt. Shui claimed that in 2010, he realized just how serious his crime was and that he needed to take responsibility for the offence. He told the parole board he had killed Annan because of his extremely bad temper, which was triggered by their differences in opinion. Shui stated, At the time, divorce would have served the problem. I should not have committed this kind of extremely serious mistake.
他的监狱记录显示他表现良好，似乎遵守了各项规章制度。当假释委员会询问水如何解决自己的暴力倾向时，他回答说：“首先，我感到非常悔恨。我想向所有受到伤害的人道歉。”水声称，他在2010年意识到自己的罪行有多么严重，并意识到自己需要为这一犯罪行为承担责任。他告诉假释委员会，他杀死安楠是因为自己极坏的脾气，而这脾气是由他们的意见分歧所引发的。水表示：“当时，离婚本可以解决问题。我不应该犯下这种极其严重的错误。”
However, Shui's claim that he had taken responsibility as early as 2010 seemed unlikely, given that he was still appealing his innocence up until 2011. When asked whether abducting his daughter and abandoning her in Melbourne was also a mistake, Shui replied, Yes. At the time, I brought my child to Australia in order to escape from this. It was very inconvenient to bring her along. He explained that when he saw police were present at Southern Cross Station, he had concluded it would be safe to leave Chan Shun there, as she would be looked after by law enforcement. The parole board ultimately rejected Shui's application.
然而，水声称自己早在2010年就已承担责任的说法似乎不太可能，鉴于他直到2011年还在就自己的无罪进行上诉。当被问及绑架女儿并将其遗弃在墨尔本是否也是一个错误时，水回答说：“是的。当时我把孩子带到澳大利亚是为了逃避这一切。带着她很不方便。”他解释说，当他看到警察出现在南部十字车站时，他断定把陈顺留在那里是安全的，因为执法人员会照顾她。假释委员会最终拒绝了水的申请。
Although his parole assessment report stated that he was at low risk of re-offending, a psychological report concluded the opposite. Moreover, if released, Shui would be required to undertake a group rehabilitation program that was conducted entirely in English, and it was determined that his English was not fluent enough for him to participate. Shui is scheduled to reappear in front of the parole board in March 2021 for his next hearing. Following Shui's arrest and conviction, New Zealand's Family Violence Court came under scrutiny, as politicians and the public questioned why he had ever been in a position where he could harm his wife, given his history of domestic violence. In 2009, then-mayor of Waitakere,
尽管他的假释评估报告指出他再次犯罪的风险较低，但一份心理学报告却得出了相反的结论。此外，如果获释，水将被要求参加一个完全用英语进行的团体戒治项目，经评估发现他的英语流利程度不足以让他参与其中。水预计将于2021年3月再次出庭接受假释委员会的下一次听证。在水被捕并定罪后，新西兰的家庭暴力法庭受到了严格审查，因为政客和公众纷纷质疑，鉴于其家庭暴力史，他怎么会落到一个能够伤害妻子的地步。2009年，时任怀塔克雷市长
Bob Harvey, spoke out against Judge Phil Recodon's decision to give Shui a suspended sentence for his brutal assault against Danon, stating, I'm absolutely bloody appalled. I feel sometimes the court system fails families, it fails women, and this is a real example of that. There's something seriously wrong here. Too many people, for reasons I cannot understand, are let off with warnings and a slap on the wrist, and it's got to stop. Judge Recodon refused to comment on the grounds that, quote, constitutional convention required that judges don't discuss specific cases in the media. Chief District Court Judge Russell Johnson came to Judge Recodon's defense,
鲍勃·哈维（Bob Harvey）公开抨击菲尔·雷科登法官（Judge Phil Recodon）对水残酷殴打达农（Danon）一案给予缓刑的决定，他表示：“我绝对是见鬼的震惊。我觉得有时司法系统辜负了家庭，辜负了女性，这就是一个真实的例子。这里面有严重的问题。太多人了，出于我无法理解的原因，仅仅得到警告和轻描淡写的惩罚就被放过了，这种情况必须停止。”雷科登法官拒绝置评，理由是“宪法惯例要求法官不得在媒体上讨论具体案件”。地区法院首席法官拉塞尔·约翰逊（Judge Russell Johnson）站出来为雷科登法官辩护，
telling reporters that prison sentences weren't suitable for a large number of cases brought before the Family Violence Court, and may actually deter victims from reporting their abuses. As Shui had no previous convictions at the time, Judge Recodon had been attempting to give the family their best chance at reconciling, and had no way of knowing that tragedy would result. Despite this assertion, Shui's abusive and controlling behaviour towards Danon met a number of key risk factors that were outlined in a 2007 New Zealand report on domestic violence risk assessments. Titled Living at the Cutting Edge, the report found that a recent or planned separation often precedes a domestic violence homicide, as disescalating levels of
他告诉记者，监禁刑罚并不适用于家庭暴力法庭审理的大量案件，甚至可能实际上阻碍受害者举报虐待行为。由于水当时没有前科，雷科登法官当时是在试图给这个家庭提供重归于好的最佳机会，根本无法预料会酿成悲剧。尽管有此断言，水对达农虐待和控制的行为符合2007年新西兰一份关于家庭暴力风险评估报告中概述的多项关键风险因素。该报告题为《生活在最前沿》（Living at the Cutting Edge），发现近期或计划中的分居往往预示着家庭暴力凶杀案的发生，伴随着不断升级的
violence and controlling behaviour. Additionally, a victim's perception that their life is in danger was noted as one of the most reliable indicators of them being at genuine risk. Annan's circumstances prior to her murder met all three of these risk factors. After a 2014 report found that about half of the country's homicides were committed by an offender who belongs to the victim's family, there have been some changes to New Zealand's Family Violence Laws. In 2018, New Zealand Parliament passed the Family Violence Act to replace the 1995 Domestic Violence Act. Among other updates, this revised legislation prioritises the safety and wellbeing of victims during sentencing decisions and requires victim
暴力和控制行为。此外，受害者认为自己生命受到威胁的感知被列为她们处于真正危险之中的最可靠指标之一。安楠在被谋杀前的情况符合这全部三个风险因素。在2014年的一份报告发现该国约有一半的凶杀案是由属于受害者家属的施暴者所犯下的之后，新西兰的家庭暴力法案进行了一些修改。2018年，新西兰议会通过了《家庭暴力法》（Family Violence Act）以取代1995年的《家庭暴力法案》。在其他更新中，这部经修订的立法优先考虑受害者在量刑决策中的安全和福祉，并要求开展
informed assessments and programs. On March 18, 2007, the group of Chinese Americans who successfully conspired to capture Naiyen Shui were formally recognised for their bravery. They received certificates of appreciation from the town of Shambli and were told they would also receive the $10,000 reward that was on offer for information leading to Shui's arrest. The group hadn't been aware of the reward, but quickly agreed on how to spend the money. They decided to donate $2,000 to an elderly friend who was unable to care for himself and to give the remaining $8,000 to Chen Shun Shui. The Little Pumpkin Trust Fund, established by Chen Shun's half-sister Grace, attracted a total of $40,000 New Zealand Dollars.
以受害者为知情基础的评估和项目。2007年3月18日，成功合谋抓捕耐茵·水的这群美籍华人群体因其勇敢行为获得了正式表彰。他们收到了尚布利镇颁发的感谢状，并被告知还将获得悬赏10000美元的奖金，该奖金原本是为提供能促成水被捕的信息而设的。这群人此前并不知道这笔奖金，但很快就如何使用这笔钱达成了一致。他们决定将2000美元捐给一位无法照顾自己的年迈朋友，并将剩下的8000美元交给陈顺·水（Chen Shun Shui）。由陈顺同父异母的姐姐格蕾丝设立的小南瓜信托基金共吸引了总计40,000新西兰元的资金。
That money remains untouched in a secure New Zealand bank account where it continues to accumulate interest. After returning to China in 2007, Chen Shun settled into her new life and has thrived ever since. Friend of the family, Pan Zi Wong, stated, she's a very mature and sensible girl. She's been to her mum's grave to pay her respects. Chen Shun's family have expressed their desire to give her as much privacy as possible, but have also shared their gratitude to New Zealanders for their support. In Anen's final blog entry, which was published at around midnight the day before her murder, she wrote about the grief and sorrow she was experiencing in her life.
这笔钱原封不动地存放在一个安全的新西兰银行账户中，并在那里继续滚存利息。2007年回到中国后，陈顺适应了她的新生活，此后一直茁壮成长。家庭友人潘子旺（Pan Zi Wong）表示：“她是一个非常成熟懂事的女孩。她去过她妈妈的墓地表达敬意。”陈顺的家属表达了希望尽可能给她提供隐私的愿望，但也向新西兰人民的支持表达了感激之情。在安楠的最后一篇博客文章中——该文章大约在她被谋杀前一天的午夜发表，她写到了她在生活中经历的悲伤与痛苦。
However, she also reflected on the importance of remembering happier times, writing, At the end of bad luck, brightness will come. I will keep the good memories in mind. It's what you have already had and cherish that won't end. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
然而，她也反思了铭记快乐时光的重要性，写道：“厄运的尽头，光明终将到来。我会把美好的回忆记在心中。只有你已经拥有并珍惜的，才不会消逝。”本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。